hi there steve kaufman here
today is november the 11th in canada
where it's remembrance day canadians
remember
the many people
who laid down their lives who sacrificed
their lives at very young ages
in order to defend our country
uh in canada in the first world war 330
000 people
volunteered to fight in the second world
war over a million canadians volunteered
to fight
which is an enormous number of people
who courageously
ended up you know
running great danger and in many cases
they never returned
i would have a poppy if i had remembered
to bring one from vancouver
um but i don't have a puppy but
nevertheless i think it's important to
remember people who made these
sacrifices for us
today i want to talk about
power language learning of course i'm in
week two of my power language learning
challenge
i set myself the goal of studying three
languages every day
arabic persian and turkish and in each
language i'm going to create a hundred
links which means that i'm going to save
100 new words names don't count words in
the language every day i save a hundred
of them
i can report that i have been
maintaining this level every day
i do this now uh it does change my
language learning
activities to some extent because i i
have to begin by making sure i get my
hundred
links created
and when i don't i end up sitting there
at 10 30 at night
creating links in order to meet that
goal
so it's a bit of a distortion i've also
discovered something i think rather
important and that is that coercion
works all right
i always say we need to learn from
interesting content compelling content
the sort of
intrinsic motivation our interest in the
subject matter
you know our positive attitude towards
the language all of these things are
very important and can be tremendously
motivating however
it is also true that some degree of
coercion
works so
what do i mean by that
i now have set myself this mechanical
goal
of saving a hundred links every day in
each language
okay what that does is it forces me into
first of all more difficult content
where there are more unknown words
forces me into content where i have
trouble understanding
what it's all about
it forces me out of my comfort zone
but i find that
as i do that
a number of things happen
first of all
when i go back to the easier material it
seems easier possibly that's because i'm
doing three languages so that
pushing my brain a little bit when i go
back to something that i have done
before that's easy it seems clearer than
before i notice better than i did before
or so it seems it's also encouraging to
go back to something
that is easy after you struggle with
things that are difficult
and
i find that
in choosing content to study whereas
before i would deliberately seek out
things of interest and which i still do
of course i i listen to my al jazeera or
franz vadcat podcasts
in arabic i have them automatically
transcribed which means that the
transcription is not
tremendous i do the same with with
turkish and with with farsi
uh
and so i struggle with these i struggle
with them because it's difficult to
understand them
and so when i go and now scour our
library
for content that's easier or at least
properly transcribed i find that i'm not
so fussy about how interesting
intrinsically interesting the material
is because i'm motivated by this
mechanical and very
clearly defined goal i have to find a
hundred new words i have to save a
hundred new words i have to create a
hundred new links in the language and i
get a great sense of satisfaction from
doing that and so it's a bit like the
french say la petite via a major the
appetite comes with the eating as i
go back to some of these
perhaps less interesting
items in our library and persian or
arabic
i i do them now because i want to create
my 100 links
and i know that the transcripts are
accurate
so it's just a reminder that that there
are different ways for us to be
motivated
for me the 100 links a day is a
self-imposed
goal no one has told me i have to do
that i've decided to do that so i've
i've created some
self-imposed coercion
to make sure that i keep driving forward
into new
material or at least material that has
unknown words in it
now
i still go back and listen to earlier
material i still have to go back and i
want to go back
and read material where i have
basically saved all the words so it's
full of yellow words which i still can't
remember
but
uh i find that this this level of
self-imposed coercion
is making sure that i put more time into
my language learning than i otherwise
would so i just sort of add that in
uh
because i i stress so often and of
course i want to get to the stage where
i can simply enjoy
my podcast in arabic
and you know it's early days here it's
10 days 10 11 days into my
power language learning challenge so i'm
hopeful that in a couple of months
i will be able to enjoy
these podcasts arabic persian turkish
that they will be less fuzzy less
ambiguous less difficult to understand
and in six months even easier and in
nine months even easier
but at least at this stage i feel a
sense of satisfaction even as i'm
swimming in all this difficult to
understand stuff that i am
at least meeting this
goal that i set for myself and that
gives me a sense of satisfaction and
achievement and when we have a sense of
satisfaction and achievement we are
encouraged and we want to continue so
thank you for listening and i want to
mention one thing
and that is if you are interested if you
would like to receive my 10 secrets
of successful language learning this is
a course in 10 emails you can receive
this free of charge by simply clicking
on the link that you see on the screen
that's it thank you for listening bye
for now